what what what and the test was positive
and I was pregnant
remember those heartbreaking moments
when your favorite childhood shows got
canceled we're letting you in on the
secret reasons these Nickelodeon shows
left our screens the brains behind many
Nickelodeon shows Dan Schneider claims
that they're wrapped up after an average
of three seasons because the audience
has a short attention span but we beg to
differ
discover the feuds the scandals and the
life-changing events that took these
shows from us too early it's not as easy
as it looks it took a lot of training
for us to get to this point it was a
devastating moment when Nickelodeon
announces victorious was ending in 2013
ariana grande victoria justice and their
co-stars have been entertaining us since
2010 through four seasons and ariana and
victoria were at the heart of the
controversy over the show's early demise
ariana was involved in the spin-off show
Sam and cat
so it made sense that fans blamed her
for the cancellation but Ariana was so
annoyed about the rumors that she
revealed her side of the story
the singer claimed that one girl chose
to do a solo tour instead of a cast tour
and Ariana was convinced that if they
had done a cast tour Nickelodeon would
have ordered another season of
Victorious while Sam and cat filmed a
simultaneously although Ariana didn't
name anyone fingers pointed towards
Victoria and that resulted in a few
between the co-stars that Victoria threw
shade back at Ariana in a tweet that's
since been deleted the Victoria wrote
that some people would throw someone
that they consider a friend under the
bus just to make themselves look good
she added a hashtag saying stop being a
phony
Ariana tweeted back saying you just
can't hide from the truth they did make
up eventually though you I am NOT an
executive I have absolutely no power
over whether or not the show continued
on
'icarly ran for longer than many
Nickelodeon shows airing from 2007 to
2012 there were so many amazing
highlights like all those guest stars
remember Michelle Obama in one direction
amazing but after seven seasons the show
ended it was still getting good ratings
so why did it stop it's likely down to
the fact that the show star miranda
cosgrove was going to college she was
ready for the next chapter in her life
and that involved furthering her
education rather than furthering the
plot lines on iCarly it's not surprising
Miranda went down that route did you
know that she was a straight-a student
she did manage to combine her love of
education and her love of acting though
by studying the cinematic arts at USC a
little too cute the actress revealed
that she went right to college after
filming stopped
although fans had to say goodbye to
Miranda I've met a lot of people there
and I just want my first football game
they could still watch her co-star
jennette mccurdy on Nickelodeon
Jeannette was back on our screens and
the spin-off Sam and cat but that didn't
end on a positive note if she gets stuck
in a toilet again will you please text
me a pic of that salmon cat debuted two
huge viewing figures in June 2013 and
after just four episodes it earned a
massive forty episodes season one order
it's not surprising giving that it was a
spinoff of two hugely popular shows
victorious and iCarly jennette mccurdy
and ariana grande played roommates who
started a babysitting service but the
show was cancelled in July 2014 ariana
wrote a long message on her socials
expressing her gratitude to the creator
and crew but she never mentioned
Jeannette so it's no wonder there were
rumors of tension between the co-stars
that was cited as a potential reason for
the show's demise there was also a lot
of chatter that it was Jeanette's
revealing photos which leaked online
that March that were to blame Jeannette
took to Twitter to explain that she
didn't turn up to the Kids Choice Awards
because she was put in an uncomfortable
compromising unfair situation I guess I
really connected with the character
because she's sort
she's like rebellious and rough and that
prompted rumors that the actress wasn't
happy with Nick
collodion about a reported pay disparity
between her and Arianna she also
explained on reddit why she left the
network saying she didn't want to be a
role model and was annoyed by how the
bubblegum industry tried to erase her
imperfections lots of drama there then
we'll just come back and break in after
you leave I don't think so
Avatar The Last Airbender aired on
Nickelodeon between 2005 and 2008 it was
so successful it had spin-off comics
manga animated sequel series and a
live-action movie and it was that movie
that spelled the end for the animated TV
series so you could say it was a victim
of its own success after three seasons a
fourth season was being planned but that
was shelved because of the live-action
adaptation the show's former head writer
Aaron Diaz led us all in on the secret
with a Twitter post on April 1st to 2019
given the date he reassured fans that
the reveal was not an April Fool's he
explained that he always intended for
Azula to have a Redemption arc and he
added that there was a moment in time
when they all thought they would do a
fourth season however along came M night
Shyamalan no matter how things may seem
to change never forget who you are the
show's executive producers wanted to
focus on the now infamous live-action
project and the 2010 movie got panned by
audiences and critics the creators are
going on to make a live-action remake of
the show for Netflix at least thanks for
being on to me
fire nation is up to something I have to
go back now Ned's Declassified School
Survival Guide originally ran on
Nickelodeon for three seasons from 2004
to 2007 the single-cam comedy followed
three best friends through middle school
and fans got excited in February 2020
when rumors swirled about a potential
reboot Devon were Kyser lindsey shaw and
daniel Curtis Lee shared photos of their
reunion on social and they teased fans
with the possibility of creating with
each other again cookie can I have your
autograph
is it true that you hang gliding into
school today landing on sweetie and
crushed him a couple of weeks later
Devon gave an interview about the show
when asked to why it was canceled he
explained that it would have had to have
been a whole new show given that baby
moving on to high school and Nickelodeon
passed on it Devon revealed that he
thinks the network was foolish for not
taking the show into the high school
years they'd done over 50 episodes and
it was a blast so Devon said there was a
sadness it was over but he also felt an
initial excitement about what's next
however he couldn't catch a break with
the next phase of his career so he got
an acting coach and went to classes for
years fans of it are so loving even now
like ten years later we've already seen
how education can be a reason for a show
to end and like iCarly education was at
the heart of why the naked Brothers
Band's starring not and Alex wolf got
canceled the mockumentary ran for three
seasons not explained that it ended
after his family and Nickelodeon
disagreed on the future of the series he
revealed that the network wanted them to
do a couple of movies but the boys
didn't really want to do that and Nick
also wanted them to do 60 episodes
during the school year however their
parents wanted them to go to school so
that meant the TV show was off the table
to the end of the movie didn't happen
where I found out about it so I think
that was the main inspiration that
there's some secretive thing that's
because according to not the network
didn't want to keep doing what they'd
been doing how did not feel about the
end of the show he reveals that he was
super bummed
however in retrospect he was really glad
it happened that's because he realized
he was on the edge of getting burned out
by the third season he was really taking
it seriously
so it all worked out for the best one of
those moments when when you start to get
hurt and then everything goes into slow
motion and my hand just went through the
fence
taina was one of the first latina LED
shows on TV airing on Nickelodeon from
2001 to 2002 the show was about the
eponymous Puerto Rican teenager and her
dream of becoming a famous singer and
actor it performed well with solid
ratings but it was canned after just two
seasons reports claimed the show was
cancelled because it only appealed to
girls but Josh Cruz who played tying his
father claimed that increasing
production costs played a part the
actress who played the part christina
vidal revealed that the team had already
written season three and the show
creator maria perez brown explained her
take on why it all went south she
explained there were talent issues and
the show stopped because there were
business deals that were signed that
were not part of the plan she also
revealed that they planned a three-part
movie so the team behind the show was
just as surprised as the audience when
it was cancelled but the creator
revealed in 2019 that there could be a
reboot with the original cast as adults
appealing to the nostalgia audience and
also with their own kids we'll keep our
fingers crossed for that we're going
further back into the nickelodeon
archives with Clarissa explains it all
Melissa Joan Hart starred as the
eponymous character for 65 episodes
although it originally aired from 1991
to 1994 you might have caught the show
when it started reruns from 2011 it took
a long time to work on each episode how
long about a total of 70 hours over six
days that's quite the time consuming
show to produce right it spawned an
album and even a board game so it's
clear just how popular it was lots of
fun stuff for you to play with no that's
why it was surprising that it got
canceled midway through its fourth
season show creator Mitchell Krugman
revealed that nickelodeon cancelled it
because they had a rigid idea about age
limits they believed that the main
character aged nearly 17 had gotten too
old for the network's audience Krugman
said that back in those days Nickelodeon
stopped out 14 at MTV
started at 15 or 16 although execs felt
it was way too old for the network the
creator believed as she could have kept
going and there wasn't really a reason
to stop from any perspective we agree
you just sat there and watched a
videotape it would make Fergie really
happy filming a show about girls being
secret mermaids in Australia sounds like
a challenge the TV series aired on
Nickelodeon from 2008 to 2009 and
returned from 2011 to 2014 it was
successful enough to spin-off an
animated series and a live-action series
but it got cancelled after just three
seasons
so why wow it sounds like production
became too difficult to continue and
that's hardly surprising the costumes
were really hard to swim in so it's no
wonder some of the actresses lost
interest it said that they wanted to
take on more serious roles in fact
claire Holt left the show after just two
seasons because she wanted to film
messengers to the Scarecrow years later
she reunited with her h2o co-star Phoebe
Tonkin on CW's the originals he forgot
one thing in your attempt to plead her
case Zoey 101 which ran from 2005 to
2008 was the most expensive series
Nickelodeon made and it was also one of
the most successful shows on the network
during that decade so it was surprising
it finished after just four seasons good
cuz there's something I got to talk to
you about yeah what's that Jamie Lynn
Spears announced her shock pregnancy at
the age of 16 in December 2007 and then
the show's cancellation was announced in
January 2008 of course fans put two and
two together
but in 2019 Jamie Lynn posted on
Instagram that zoey 101 did not end
because of the pregnancy but because her
contract had ended Jamie Lynn reunited
with many of her former co-stars on the
sketch show all that in 2019 and then
she revealed in made 2020 that she's in
talks with Nickelodeon to develop a
reboot of the show so watch this space
which of these Nickelodeon shows do you
miss the most and which of the real
reasons that they got cancelled a shock
to you the moe
be sure to subscribe to the things for
more great videos like this one thanks
for watching